hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're going
to be looking at a cool little track
trap the Magnus Smith trap and it
derives from the Fischer variation in
the Sicilian defense and since so many
of you play the Sicilian offense or see
the Sicilian defense on a very frequent
basis I want to go ahead and take a look
at this trap since I've seen it a few
times and you may come across it a few
times if you do play the Fischer
variation so it starts out with pawn to
e4 pawn to c5 Sicilian defense Knight to
f3 development move bringing the knight
to the center controlling the center
squares and blacks gonna play d6 very
common pawn to d4 developing the pawn to
a central square life's going to take
we're going to recapture with our Knight
Black's going to develop his Knight to
f6 central control at the same time
attacking our pawn on e4 we're going to
develop the same time attack the center
and defend our pawn on e4 black is going
to reciprocate and bring his knight to
c6 attacking the center and we're gonna
bring our Bishop to c4 this is the
Fischer variation this is kind of where
I want to get into and as you can see
here as many of you know if you watch my
videos the f7 Square is a huge weakness
for black especially early on when
White's LightSquared bishop can I on it
very easily and it's not protected by
much besides the black King and so this
is a very common variation that you will
see in the Sicilian defense from white
side and so Black has two options and
one is the better move and that's to
bring his pawn to e6 nice little move
here it's a little defensive and passive
but at the same time it pretty much
blocks this bishop this LightSquared
Bishop from white there's not much that
he can do the f7 squares gonna be really
hard for him to attack now with his
LightSquared bishop but a lot of times a
lot of players in this variation tend to
think that they need to bring their pawn
to g6 and I've seen it quite a few times
about half and half
and a lot of players think that they
need to be in Quetta their Bishop to g7
so that they can get more attacking on
these Center control and try to have a
counter-attack on the dark squares
I'm from the g7 square with the dark
square Bishop but this is going to be a
mistake in from here white can capture
this rook or excuse me this knight on c6
and black after he recaptures then white
has the nice little move of playing pawn
to e5 and this is really what I want to
look at right here after pawn to e5 if
black looks at it very quickly if he
tries to retake with his pawn then why
it has a nice little tactic he can play
Bishop takes on f7 and this King is
forced to take this Bishop on f7 he
can't bring his King to d7 because our
Queens here then after he takes our
bishop on f7 then we can bring in with
our queen and take his queen his queen
was only defended by this King on e8 and
once this King moves we can now take on
d8
so he can't take with his pawn even
though he would like to and at the same
time we're attacking this night here on
f6 so his knight really has two moves
for he can go he can always bring it
back to g8 but you never wanted to
develop a move develop a piece and then
bring it right back you're gonna lose a
lot of momentum as far as tempo gaining
and why it's gonna have a huge
developmental advantage so he would like
to bring it to either g4 or h5 and a lot
of times you'll see h5 if he brings it
to g4 it's gonna be very hard for him
white can play the move pawn to e6
blocking off his defender the Bishop
from c8 if he tries to take and we
recapture once he now captures we can
take with our Queen as you can see the
black king is completely unguarded
it doesn't matter which side he castles
on it's gonna be very hard for him to
stay protected at the same time White
has a very good defense he has three
pawns three pawns he can castle on the
Kings side or the Queen side so this is
gonna be very good for white he's gonna
have a pretty easy win in my opinion so
from here a lot of times instead of
Knight to g4 you'll see Knight to h5 and
from here Bobby Fischer recommends and
since Bobby Fischer says it must be true
Queen to f3 and this is a very important
move because you're putting another
attacker on this f7 square which is
again a very important weakness that
Black has and from here a lot of times
Black has two moves he really needs to
block off one of these attackers and he
can do this by one of two ways he can
bring his pawn to d5 or he can bring his
pawn to e6 he wants the easiest way is
to block out this Bishop it's also
attacker along with this Queen on f3
eyeing down on the f7 square so let's go
and take a look at the first one V if he
moves pawn to d5 then we can take with
our Knight again we can sacrifice
because if we have such a huge attack
against black and from here there's not
much that black can do here we can get
our Bishop involved if we have to but
once we take here if he if he takes for
this pawn we can take with our Bishop
and we have a queen defending it and
it's gonna be really hard for black to
defend all the attacks that we have if
instead if he plays east six now we can
bring our pawn and start to attack his
knight on h5 and again there's really
only one move he can play now he can't
bring it to f6 because we'll take it
with our pawn he's gonna bring it back
to g7 as you can already see this is a
very passive
he really wants to bring his dark square
Bishop to g7 and get it active attacking
the dark squares along this long bag and
I'll attack in the center but his dark
square Bishop is very passive now and as
many of you know the dark square bishop
for black is his most important bishop
early on in the game and right now he's
not doing anything so it's not always
how many pieces you have but how many
active pieces you have in chess this is
very important if we can have a passive
night here on g7 blocking this dark
square bishop this is very good for us
and from here we can continue and bring
our Knight to e4 and this has a lot of
problems for black there's not much he
can do here again we're attacking this
pawn on d6 we're also attacking this
square on f6 that would check the King
he would be forced to move he couldn't
take with his queen because of our pawn
here and if his King gets out in the
open it's gonna be a very easy game we
can just start to attack we can castle
on the Queen side and add another rook
attacker on the D file it's gonna be
very hard for black not to lose right
away if black has the last-ditch effort
and tries to bring his queen down to a5
as you can see right now he's attacking
this our King on e1 at the same time
attacking our pawn we can now just
develop our Bishop to d2 and if he does
take this will be another mistake we can
bring our Bishop to c3 and his queen is
tracked his Queens gonna be playing on
the sidelines and White's gonna go on to
a very easy game so as you can see it
it's really complicated for white to
find any good play here and I've tried
to play it on black side and I couldn't
find a very easy way to come up with a
draw much less a win so I really feel
like white has a very easy game from
here especially depending on where black
moves a lot of times black makes an easy
mistake early on and you can win very
easily but if he does play correct a lot
of times he is very passive in his
defense and a lot of times you can pick
it apart one by one so this is the Magna
Smith trap you'll see a lot if you
haven't tried out the Fischer variation
and this is silly in defense
I definitely recommend trying it out it
is very good for white usually scores
pretty good for white since the Sicilian
generally speaking scores pretty well
for black definitely one to try out and
again if they do play that pawn to g6
that's gonna be the huge mistake there
so hope you guys enjoyed this video on
the Magnus Smith trap if you haven't
already please subscribe and hope you
guys enjoy the video I'll see you guys
next time
thanks for watching